[Musica]
la storia della comunità umana
l'evoluzione del genere umano è sempre
segnata e storicamente assegnata dalla
dalla voglia al desiderio dal bisogno di
guardare il futuro di comprendere che
cosa ci attende in che modo possiamo
adeguare i nostri comportamenti e la
nostra vita i nostri legami sociali in
funzione del mondo che sta arrivando
nella nella storia delle culture
classiche tutto questo ho voluto dire
rivolgersi a tanti profeti a tante
figure molto particolari dal l'oracolo a
tanti e diversi sacerdoti in particolare
in questo ambito una figura che ho
sempre trovato interessante è quello
degli auguri gli auguri erano dei
sacerdoti erano tipici dell'impero
romano ma venivano in realtà della
cultura etrusca gli auguri erano coloro
chiamati a confermare le decisioni dei
politici attraverso l'osservazione del
volo degli uccelli il comportamento in
volo di stormo isolato la direzione e la
velocità le loro curve loro traiettorie
di volo erano quelle che venivano usate
per comprendersi quella decisione fosse
valevole oppure no
ho abbastanza la sensazione quando ci
occupiamo di riguardare in questo
momento che cosa ci attende ma
soprattutto di guardare anche il
presente e contemporaneo delle reti o
abbastanza la sensazione che abbiamo
bisogno di tornare a guardare il volo
degli uccelli in particolare il volo
degli stormi degli storni e il volo del
dei grandi gruppi dei grandi agglomerati
degli sciami se torniamo a guardarli ci
accorgiamo che la consistenza di questi
sciami è caratterizzata dal rapporto tra
io e noi tra il singolo individuo nella
relazione con gli altri
tipicamente nel volo degli sciami per
esempio degli storni quello questo
osserva che ogni animale in relazione
con altri cinque animali quelli che li
circondano che lo circonda
davanti è il punto centrale di questo
volo e nella interazione e nello spazio
che negli intervalli di spazio che si
realizza e all'interno del quale si
compiano strategie di volo del singolo
io e noi significa che al tempo stesso
ogni elemento ogni componente di questo
volo è un un punto individuale ma anche
un elemento del noe tornare a guardare
questo noi significa tornare a guardare
fondamentalmente un'evoluzione che non
abbiamo più compiuto nel novecento e
novecento il secolo delle masse e secolo
di gruppi indistinti è un secolo di un
noi usato strumentalmente probabilmente
più il secolo del voi fate questo essa
con la indicativo qualcuno che indica la
direzione e la massa si muove rimettere
in discussione questo vuol dire
riguardare alcuni concetti a cui ci
siamo affezionati
il mercato di massa la comunicazione di
massa
tanti riferimenti in cui c'è una massa
indistinta che pretendiamo che abbia un
solo soggetto che esista come se fosse
un solo ente quello che sta accadendo
negli ultimi vent'anni ma quello che sta
accadendo nelle reti e che invece ci
sono sciami che si muovono in cui io e
noi vivono lo stesso tempo quello che
dobbiamo sanare con più attenzione sono
gli spazi di infra gli intervalli le
intersezioni gli elementi tra i vari
elementi stessi
tutto ciò che si va a configurare e
tutto ciò che accade nello spazio tra le
cose e in questo senso forse vale la
pena di rivolgersi ad una piccola storia
una storia fatta di una strana vicenda
che inizia nel seicento osservata in
particolare in un piccola in una piccola
cittadina della fiona che è una delle
isole della danimarca la stessa dove c'è
odense in questo paesino che si chiama
carte min
c'è la classica strada che va verso il
porto
la classica strada danese fatta di
casetta è un piano più il tetto e la
cosa particolare è che fin dal seicento
in ognuna di queste finestre che dà su
una stradina ci sono due specchi
retrovisori due specchietti che se ci
mettiamo all'interno di quelle stanze ci
fanno vedere ciò che accade alla
sinistra della casa ciò che accade a
destra
la spiegazione potrebbe essere
rintracciata dall'idea del cercare di
sapere ogni giorno tutte le persone
andate alla pesca sono rientrate in
qualche modo c'è un'attività di tutta la
comunità nell'accompagnare questi
lavoratori del mare fino agli usci di
casa è abbastanza improbabile immaginare
che attraverso questi specchi si tenesse
d'occhio il gioco dei bambini per le
strade
siamo in danimarca quindi un clima è
propriamente quello che favorisce il
gioco della strada ma quello che è molto
interessante che se proviamo a guardare
questi questi specchi e le immagini che
si formano in questi specchi
dall'interno delle stanze ci accorgiamo
inevitabilmente che una persona entra da
dallo specchio di sinistra transita al
centro nell'intervallo tra i due specchi
e poi riappare nel terzo specchia nel
secondo specchio quello che per esempio
nel loro caso guarda verso il porto è un
punto interessante anche un po
divertente l'idea che alcune figure si
siano smarrite tra una riflessione
all'altra cioè che alcuni alcune persone
sono entrate nello specchio di sinistra
e siano magicamente riapparse dopo un
tempo che può essere indefinito corto o
lunghissimo dopo essere scomparsa in
questo breve intervallo in
quell'intervallo si compia il tempo in
quell'intervallo per esempio può
capitare di vedere entrare un bambino e
poi veder uscire dall altro specchio
anziano e si è consumato un intera vita
a questo intervallo tra le due
riflessioni
potremmo anche immaginare per esempio
che qualcuno sia entrato
più che giovane cioè da ragazzino
letteralmente e non sia sbucato
dall'altra parte si sia perso
completamente nello spazio
dell'intervallo negli intervalli si
realizzano le possibilità negli
intervalli normalmente noi perdiamo i
nostri riferimenti noi guardiamo il
futuro basandolo sulla probabilità che
le cose accadano in questo caso questo
esempio degli specchi ci aiuta a capire
che ogni cosa è possibile invece
dell'intervallo è che dovremmo imparare
a guardare il futuro ea guardare le reti
ea guardare le interazioni attraverso
gli sguardi del possibile non nel
probabile troppo spesso accade che
viviamo il tempo futuro basandolo su ciò
che ci sembra più probabile ma a quel
punto quel futuro non arriverà perché
l'abbiamo già vissuto il futuro che
arriverà è uno di quelli possibili non è
mai uno di quelli probabili credo che
questo faccia parte anche
dell'esperienza di vita di ciascuno di
noi
in quel in quello spazio di intervallo
tra quegli specchi si possono consumare
una serie di eventi e non a caso siamo
nella danimarca in questo racconto
vicino a quei paesi bassi a quell olanda
dove è nata la leggenda del vascello
fantasma dell'olandese volante
raccontata da wagner
brevemente questa storia di questo
capitano del di navi che
nell'attraversare con tanta difficoltà
il capo di buona speranza si rivolge con
male parole a dio e viene condannato
vagare per l'eternità negli oceani e
solamente alla fine affrontando ogni
sette anni una grande tempesta avrà la
possibilità sopravvivendo quella
tempesta di tornare a terra e solamente
se incontrerà l'amore di una donna e
saprà condividerlo
finalmente la sua condanna finirà ancora
negli anni 70 nel 1970 ma ancora negli
anni novanta del secolo scorso si
raccontava di qualcuno che avesse visto
in giro per gli oceani questo vascello
nero con le vele rosse che ancora vaga
si è disperso tra due intervalli tra due
intervalli di sette anni
non a caso questa leggenda nascono lì
questi miti nascono rete ma non è un
caso che ci danno la distruzione di
indicazione di guardare meglio agli
intervalli tra le cose ea capire
all'interno di questi intervalli quali
siano quegli eventi quei comportamenti
quel quelle variazioni che dobbiamo
costantemente considerare in questo
senso c'è un piccolo esempio che
possiamo fare che ci vede in questa
epoca è un esempio che ci aiuta a capire
il caso del rapporto
oggi tutta la nostra civiltà quella
digitale particolare si è stabilizzata
intorno al sistema binario al rapporto
tra 0 e 1 tutte le cose vengono tradotte
in un linguaggio di sequenza infinita di
0 1
nel modo in cui li configuriamo possiamo
poi ricostruire immagini parole
trasferire nostri file navigare in rete
il rapporto tra 0 e 1 e un rapporto che
ci sembra costrittivo che ci costringa a
ragionare sempre solo su due enti o 6 0
6 1 6 bianco 6 nero la verità
la comprensibile da un punto di vista
matematico tra 0 e 1 c'è l'infinito 0,1
all'infinito 0,2 all'infinito e questa è
un'idea filosoficamente interessante
l'idea che il fatto che un infinito
possa essere contenuto tra due confini
allora il sistema binario e un diverso
modo di pensare il sistema binario ci
favorisce
l'idea che dobbiamo imparare in questo
secolo
in questo secolo di reti connesse in
questo secolo di champ interconnessi a
ragionare meglio il nostro rapporto con
l'infinito il novecento è stato il
secolo del finito del dei prodotti
finiti dell'industria finita
dall'organizzazione definita in tutte le
sue caratteristiche
questo grazie alle reti sarà il secolo
in cui dovremo rapportarci e lo dicono
anche i sistemi complessi
dobbiamo rapportarci ad un'idea di
infinito l'infinito è fatto di
possibilità non di probabilità
l'infinito è fatto di traiettorie che
non riusciamo a vedere in anticipo non
predicibili non visibili non
immediatamente matematicamente
determinate uno degli aspetti che
connotano di più questa evoluzione anche
teme di nostro comportamento può essere
notato guardando un piccolo sistema che
in questo momento che piega un
cambiamento morfologico e cognitivo
da un'indagine del tutto sommaria
sappiamo che più o meno una persona su
quattro scrive sms e whatsapp sui propri
apparati telefonici gli scrive col dito
indice
gli altri tre persone su quattro hanno
imparato usano prevalentemente il
pollice questo che sembra una banalità è
in realtà un cambiamento sostanziale
nella nostra attitudine nel modo in cui
ci rapportiamo le cose quello che ci
aspetta nei prossimi anni
e l'idea di rapportarci primariamente
alle cose attraverso il pollice e non
più attraverso l'indice
l'indice lo dice la parola stessa
indicativo l'indice è la ragione della
massa
l'indice è qualcuno che ci indica la
direzione ci dice andate lì la stessa
cosa non la potremo prendere sul serio
se utilizzassimo il pollice il pollice
che nella storia dell'uomo sarebbero
paul ojika è quello che ci connota in
termini di opposizione e pollice che ci
dà la possibilità che ci ha dato la
possibilità di utilizzare un bastone per
procurarsi il cibo o di pre raccogliere
una pietra per poterla tirare quindi è
il pollice opponente si dice il pollice
rappresenta in qualche modo una forma di
maggior libertà rispetto all'indice il
rapporto tra indicativo e libertà in
qualche modo e opposizione e conferma
soprattutto pensiamo facebook
pensiamo alla alle icone del pollice
segnano un radicale cambiamento che non
è solo culturale e anche letteralmente
prossimale ma di interazione
se proviamo a immaginare le nostre case
nostri uffici
tutti gli interruttori per accendere
luci sono fatti per essere usati con
l'indice se proviamo usarli col pollice
quasi sempre andiamo a battere le nocche
contro il muro
cosa cosa sta accadendo che chi si è
accorto di questa variazione sta
probabilmente immaginando di togliere
gli interruttori e infatti nascono i
comandi vocali
chi invece rimane permane all'interno di
una dinamica tipicamente novecentesca
non sia posto il problema e continua a
usare di indice immaginare un mondo in
cui si continuerà a usare l'indice per
fare certe cose ma la prevalenza 3 su 4
utilizzeranno il pollice questo
cambiamento legato al pollice significa
che in qualche modo si vanno a costruire
nuovi riti del corpo nuovi riti nel modo
di pensare le cose e ogni rituale
inventa un nuovo presente e quindi
favorisce un diverso futuro
se mettiamo questo in relazione al tema
per esempio del passaggio dalla massa
agli sciami comprendiamo che sta
nascendo una nuova forma di intelligenza
un intelligenza collettiva che si
comporta e sperimenta fa esperienza di
nuovi comportamenti questa intelligenza
estesa questa mente estesa questa
intelligenza connettiva a delle
problematiche se non siamo ancora
allenati a considerarla cosa succede che
oggi la maggior parte degli sciami
online si comportano come uno sciame di
cavallette piombano su un soggetto
distruggono mangiano azzerano qualunque
forma di vita naturale ma ci sono anche
gli sciami d'api ci sono gli sciami di
storni ci sono gli stormi di sardine di
sarde e dentro a questo possiamo capire
che lì c'è un intervallo lì sono
intervallo che ci dobbiamo dare all
intervallo in cui dobbiamo renderci
conto prima di tutto che stiamo
crescendo su modalità cognitiva di
apprendimento basate su codici multipli
non più solo su codici orali o legati
alla scrittura
comunichiamo ea prendiamo molto di più
all'interno di sistemi di interazione
tra persone tra persone cose tra cose
cose tutto questo sta disegnando un
nuovo e diverso mondo un mondo in cui la
vera finalità il vero punto sarà quello
di riuscire
a creare dei nuovi luoghi dei luoghi
dove si possono esercitare quelle
interazioni di nuova tipologia ma
interazioni legate a delle finalità ma
con l'idea di essere il traguardo
raggiunto dallo sciame una volta
raggiunto si ristrutturano per
riconfigurarsi da un'altra parte
questa è l'immagine per una nuova
dimensione per una nuova idea trattativa
delle reti e l'idea stessa di un mondo
che è in continua variazione
rimescolamento se guardiamo i voli degli
sciami in realtà abbiamo forme che
mutano abbiamo parti elementi che escono
e rientrano che si uniscono ad altri
sciami c'è un buttare continuo
siamo pronti ad accettare questo siamo
pronti a lavorarci dentro siamo pronti a
svolgere il ruolo costruttivo che in
relazione all'ambiente che costruire che
quindi rappresentano e che in cui
operano le api o continuiamo a ragionare
appunto come lo sciame di cavallette che
lavorano su tempeste sutor mente basate
sulla distruzione delle cose
questo è il passaggio chiave nei
prossimi anni ed è solo attraverso
questo cambiamento di sguardo questo
cambiamento di comportamenti che
potremmo immaginare una nuova forma di
vita collettiva di democrazia su cui
basare un futuro possibile uno dei tanti
futuri possibili
che cosa fare per questo guardare sempre
di più gli intervalli capire gli spazi
tra le cose entrare in interazione
costruire nuove forme di interazione il
nostro futuro è una forma di destino che
però noi possiamo contribuire a
progettare non a caso la radice della
parola design lavori alla radice che
viene da disegno del signor è una radice
indoeuropea
che significa destino ogni volta che
progettiamo qualcosa stiamo intervenendo
sull'intero destino dell'intera umanità